[Musique]
lors de la dernière présidentielle
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait récolté plus de
32% des voix chez les 18 24 ans avec ce
documentaire la réalisatrice Ludivine
Tomasi a donc tenté vous venez de le
voir de comprendre les ressorts de ce
succès en donnant la parole à de jeunes
militants de la France insoumise mais
aussi à son leader et nous allons en
débattre maintenant avec nos invités
présents aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de
débat doc avec vous pour commencer
Nathalie osiol bienvenue vous êtes
député et les filles de l'Hérault sur la
circonscription de Montpellier et membre
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de l'Assemblée nationale vous avez 33
ans et vous êtes agrégé d'anglais que
vous avez enseigné dans un lycée de
Béziers
votre adhésion a elle est fi remonte à
2016 autrement dit au moment de la
création de ce mouvement adhésion par un
clic puisque ça semble la formule pour
adhérer à ce mouvement comme ça que vous
des réalités en fait j'ai rejoint un
groupe qui distribuait des tracts devant
une université
et ensuite effectivement lorsqu'on veut
être recevoir en tout cas les
informations et l'actualité de la France
insoumise et bien ça se passe sur notre
plateforme en ligne que j'ai rejoint et
puis et ben une fois que j'y ai pris
goût je n'ai plus quitter le
militantisme et puis alors six ans après
c'est adhésion et les filles vous avez
été élu député de l'Hérault avec cette
phrase juste après votre élection
prononcée chez nos confrères de France
Bleu aujourd'hui je porte la colère des
gens et donc on va y revenir bien sûr
dans un instant également avec nous
Olivier Pérou bienvenue et vous êtes
grand reporter au service politique de
l'hebdomadaire L'Express en charge de la
gauche et votre dernier livre pour titre
autopsie du cadavre le cadavre en
question s'appelle le Parti socialiste
et cet ouvrage est à découvrir aux
éditions Fayard et puis enfin avec nous
Rémi Lefebvre bienvenue vous êtes
politologue professeur de sciences
politiques à l'Université de Lille les
chercheurs au Centre d'études et de
recherche administratives politiques et
sociales c'est le séraps votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule lui faut-il
désespérer de la gauche il est à se
procurer aux éditions textuelles Rémi
Lefer on va commencer avec vous
j'imagine que vous l'avez scanné cette
jeunesse qui s'engage dans les rangs de
la France insoumise sociologiquement à
l'effet de quoi cette jeunesse qui
s'engage dans ce mouvement la France
insoumise alors attention la jeunesse
c'est pas un groupe homogène il y a une
jeunesse qui vote pour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais aussi une jeunesse qui
vote beaucoup pour l'extrême droite et
qui présente pas du tout les mêmes
caractéristiques sociales
qui nous intéresse aujourd'hui c'est
celle qui s'engage du côté de la France
elle est plutôt
urbaine elle est plutôt diplômée elle
est plutôt féministe elle est plutôt
très sensible par exemple au vu violence
policière et elle trouve en fait dans
dans l'offre politique incarnée par la
France un marqueur de gauche un marqueur
bien identifié alors que très souvent
cette jeunesse elle est un petit peu
perdue dans ses repères elle a connu les
déceptions du mandat de François
Hollande elle a connu le brouillage du
clivage gauche-droite et parce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon incarne une forme de
radicalité écologiste féministe bien
identifié cette gauche là effectivement
à trouver dans Jean-Luc Mélenchon un
repère et ces mobilisé lors de la
dernière érection présidentielle alors
vous ne faites pas partie de ceux qui
classifient elle et fille la France
insoumise
d'extrêmement l'extrême gauche dite
radical et les sièges néanmoins à
l'extrême gauche de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale
néanmoins est-ce que vous vous diriez
que la France insoumise et la nouvelle
gauche révolutionnaire cette gauche
révolutionnaire qui au côté de la gauche
dit très formides progressiste a fait
l'histoire de la gauche française c'est
compliqué c'est une gauche
révolutionnaire parce que j'ai envie de
prône la révolution citoyenne donc il
prône bien une transformation radicale
du système du système libéral mais c'est
pas forcément une gauche anticapitaliste
c'est pas la gauche de du NPA ou de
Lutte Ouvrière c'est à dire que
globalement c'est une transformation
radicale du système économique mais
c'est pas la révolution au sens où l'on
entendu dans dans l'histoire du
mouvement ouvrier voilà donc le
programme de Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est
aussi à gauche que l'été le programme de
de François Mitterrand en 1981 donc
évidemment il est beaucoup plus à gauche
que le programme
sociaux-démocrates mais c'est pas non
plus l'extrême gauche c'est à dire que
c'est aussi une gauche républicaine qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre du système
républicain mais qui effectivement prône
une rupture radicale avec le système
néolibéral alors changer le système on
l'a entendu dans la bouche de certain
nombre de méditantes et de jeunes
militantes que nous avons vu dans dans
ce documentaire on va réécouter ce que
disait justement à ce propos l'une
d'entre elles
quand on regarde le bilan on a recréé
une forme d'unité à gauche sur la base
d'un score qui était quand même de 22%
ce qui est immense c'est à dire que là
on s'est remis du hollandisme on a mis à
distance
cette gauche qui dit qui en fait avec
complètement intégré que bon il y a le
système tel qu'il est puis on va essayer
de le rendre un petit peu mon brutal
quoi voilà et en fait c'est pas l'enjeu
très peu classe l'enjeu pour ma
génération c'est de changer le système
donc ce que vous proposez ce que veulent
ces jeunes si on comprend bien c'est une
rupture avec le système actuel oui
effectivement Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
théorisé la révolution citoyenne quand
on dit révolution citoyenne c'est que on
part du constat que aujourd'hui
la Cinquième République notamment
se déroule dans l'intérêt d'une poignée
de gens très riches qui sont ceux qui
par leur mode de vie polluent le plus
par exemple et
[Musique]
que tout cela a suscité une espèce de
désadhésion de de renonciation contre
laquelle nous nous battons par exemple
lorsque on peut en prendre le passage à
la Sixième République lorsqu'on prône
des modes de production radicalement
différents qui permettrait de mettre en
place une écologie radicale populaire et
puis bon bah pour que la rupture la
rupture on y a déjà eu le droit dans le
discours politique 80 Mitterrand c'était
la rupture avec le capitalisme bon un
peu plus proche de nous François
Hollande avait fait du monde de la
finance son ennemi il y a eu beaucoup de
déçus à gauche sans doute beaucoup de
déçus au sein même de l'électorat qui
pourrait qui aurait pu voter
un parti comme la France insoumise
aujourd'hui et du coup alors qu'est-ce
qui peut faire croire à ces jeunes
qu'est-ce qui peut faire croire qu'avec
vous la rupture elle est programmée bel
et bien programmée et que si vous
arrivez au pouvoir vous allez y parvenir
alors déjà bon parce qu'on a un
programme l'avenir en commun qui a été
porté pendant l'élection présidentielle
qui est ensuite on a porté le programme
de la nupes qui depuis peut être
augmenté des combats que nous avons mené
en commun à la nups à l'Assemblée
nationale qui porte toutes sortes de
mesures sociales écologiques
démocratique et puis cela s'accompagne
de gages également par exemple lorsque
on propose un référendum révocatoire à
mi-mandat lorsque bon ce sont des gages
effectivement qui permettent de dire que
lorsqu'on fait une promesse ça ne doit
pas être une promesse en l'air parce que
bon c'est clair que les promesses elles
ont été rompues
vous allez la porter comment parce que
ça c'est effectivement c'est souvent des
propos contient quand on est dans
est-ce que vous en sentez prête
affronter le réel en tant qu’élu
aujourd'hui est-ce que ces jeunes qu'on
a vu dans ce documentaire peut vous
aussi accepter l'idée d'un certain
nombre de compromis s'il s'agissait
demain d'affronter le réel et la gauche
française a été confrontée au réel dans
son histoire et ça semble toujours été
un peu un problème c'est de
confrontation avec le réel vous y sentez
prêt aujourd'hui en tant que élu et les
filles ces jeunes s'ils sont prêts à vos
yeux
si on s'appuie sur les résultats de
l'élection présidentielle
on l'a entendu Jean-Luc Mélenchon
obtient 22% 22% des voix toutes les
autres formations de gauche qu'on
pourrait qualifier d'accompagnement du
libéralisme de ce que Emmanuel Macron a
porté jusqu'à maintenant ont été
sanctionnés dans les urnes et font moins
de 5%. donc ce qui a été porté par la
jeunesse mais pas que par les électrices
et les électeurs de la France insoumise
c'est un programme de rupture
et donc cela bon
ça ça aussi quelque chose que l'on doit
prendre en compte en tout cas
et c'est ce qu'on s'efforce de faire
mais quand je disais que nous nous
sommes en rupture aussi avec l'ordre
établi avec cette cinquième république
qui privilégie une poignée de gens ça
signifie qu'il faut réconcilier aussi le
grand nombre à la politique et on a par
exemple mené des campagnes d'inscription
sur les listes électorales et on sait
très bien que les jeunes par exemple
sont souvent mal inscrits parce que ils
n'étudie pas là où il vote forcément
parce que encore très peu voté à
comparer à leurs aînés aux dernières
élections la présidentielle de nous
avons été la seule formation politique à
faire des campagnes de porte-à-porte y
compris dans les cités universitaires
par exemple pour
chez les 18 24 ans et ce documentaire
que nous avons vu ensemble Olivier
perron cette jeunesse elle est fille et
ce parti ce mouvement ce mouvement la
France insoumise s'il y a de la colère
chez chez les jeunes et notamment chez
les jeunes qui votent à la pour la
France soumise il y a aussi beaucoup de
frustration parce que quand on entend
dans le documentaire dire que c'est 22%
c'est immense ça ne gagne pas donc les
jeunes y compris ceux qui votent pour la
France insoumise il y a une forme de
frustration d'être aussi et encore dans
l'opposition et je pense que si une
grande partie de la jeunesse aujourd'hui
votre pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est
moins pour le fond que pour la manière
de faire de la politique je n'ai pas
entendu au fil de mes reportages au fil
de la campagne présidentielle les jeunes
qui militaient pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
réclamait la Sixième République même si
ils y sont attachés sur ce changement de
de régime c'est pas au cœur de leur
préoccupations néanmoins ce que a
compris Jean-Luc Mélenchon et c'est là
qui est intéressant c'est la manière de
leur parler et il faut se souvenir quand
même que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
à un peu plus de 70 ans il fait la
politique depuis très longtemps donc
c'est vrai routier de la politique
professionnelle de la politique comme il
en a existé durant on pourrait croire
que finalement les jeunes n'aiment pas
pardonner moi l'expression les vieux de
la vieille de la politique et pourtant
ils adhèrent à ce discours il y a
plusieurs raisons
juste un exemple à la fin des années 80
il est l'un des plus jeunes sénateurs et
il est en adéquation et à l'époque il
est parti socialiste et il en sur une
ligne politique très proche de ceux qui
animent SOS Racisme ou qui forment le
syndicat lycéen la fidèle notamment pour
combattre la loi de vaquer et ces gens
là donc c'était Julien Dray ou Eric
benze écrit par exemple qui ont été des
collaborateurs et des proches de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon donc c'est eux qui
anime ces réseaux et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
voit ses mouvements de jeunesse
s'activer massivement à l'époque ils
regardent ça du coin de l'oeil même si
c'est un très jeune sénateur il ne
comprend pas comment
c'est ces deux ces deux hommes arrivent
à mobiliser tous ces jeunes dans la rue
regarde ça avec un peu de jalousie
presque et donc il va un peu s'inspirer
tout ça et ça mène un peu à ça
aujourd'hui il faut veut dire qu'à
l'époque Jean-Luc Mélenchon même s'il
avait 35 ans quand il était sénateur il
était vu comme un vieux sénateur
mitterrandiste et ça le discours
n'accrochait pas la jeunesse aujourd'hui
ouais juste sur un point aujourd'hui
Mélenchon a compris ça notamment parce
qu'il met beaucoup de jeunes autour de
lui tout son entourage peut parler de
Clémence guetter qui est une jeune et
peut-être qu'il prend des
responsabilités et les réseaux sociaux
Tik Tok il a très vite compris que c'est
sur ce réseau qui pourrait aussi
conscientiser il y a des millions de
personnes qui le regardent et et ça il y
est très attaché et il essaye de parler
aux jeunes via ce médium alors ce
contact de Jean-Luc Mélenchon 71 ans je
crois aujourd'hui au moment où on se
parle et ces jeunes c'est 18 24 ans il
est symbolisé par un extrait du
documentaire notamment
à propos du privilège blanc
ce serait mentir de dire que qu'il n'y a
pas de racisme d'État c'est à dire qu'on
est dans un pays où quelque soit notre
statut social à part si un moment on
n'est pas blanc on aura des difficultés
quand on ressent justement le ce
privilège d'être un homme blanc je sais
pas on s'en rend pas compte il faut que
les autres vous le disent au début moi
j'ai commencé par dire non mais ça va
pas c'est quoi le privilège d'un homme
blanc quand il est pauvre m'a dit bah va
te le raconter et puis quand on vous le
raconte bah vous dites c'est pas que
faux quoi et parce que ça touche à tout
ça touche à l'intime vous vous
définiriez comment alors être humain je
n'appartiens à aucune communauté fondée
sur la couleur de peau ça jamais quelle
horreur je n'appartiens aucune
communauté
sur la couleur de peau
là on retrouve Jean-Luc Mélenchon plutôt
Laïka qui s'inscrit pleinement dans
notre universalisme républicain et puis
qui discute avec une jeune femme qui
qui fait partie de ceux comme vous les
avez décrivés qui sont contre les
évidemment pour lutter contre les
discriminations raciales
du discrimination de genre
il a fallu s'adapter pour Mélenchon
néanmoins pour s'adresser à cette
jeunesse c'est très intéressant ce
passage là parce qu'en fait Mélenchon
très clairement son logiciel il fait
combien vous l'avez dit les Leica il est
universalisme c'est-à-dire que pour lui
bon la religion c'est quelque chose il
est anticlérical bon athée évidemment il
est pour une formation
qui était très très riste et donc les
questions de qu'on peut qualifier
aujourd'hui de walkiste de d'air du
temps
par exemple pendant longtemps le mot
islamophobie Jean-Luc Mélenchon daignait
l'existence de l'islamophobie et il a
évolué et il a évolué à partir de 2017
c'est notamment aussi les députés
issus de la Seine-Saint-Denis par
exemple quelqu'un comme Eric Coquerel
qui dit avoir beaucoup évolué sur ces
questions là il a voulu aussi beaucoup
parce qu'il entourait de jeunes vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est très
important les assistants parlementaires
les cadres de la France insoumise qui
eux ont une culture beaucoup plus
ouverte sur
avec ce discours là qui qui résonne en
eux en fait est-ce que vous ce sont les
représentants et les jeunes issus des
classes populaires qui vous ont en
partie élu vous aussi à l'occasion des
dernières législatives alors oui moi ma
circonscription donc c'est une
circonscription particulière qui n'est
que sur Montpellier pas tout le monde
Montpellier mais une grande partie donc
ça elle comprend des quartiers comme le
centre-ville autant que la Paillade ou
des quartiers très populaires oui la
candidature de Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans
certains bureaux on a beaucoup voté aux
yeux oui oui Jean-Luc Mélenchon après de
80% des bases 80% et ma candidature pas
toujours on a toujours cette dualité
entre il y a une abstention qui reste
très forte mais lorsque les gens se
déplacent ils se déplacent pour la
France insoumise Jean-Luc Mélenchon au
présidentiel Nathalie Oziol pour la
Législative ici on voit en fait
la théorie universaliste que nous
portons c'est à dire lorsque
[Musique]
ces problématiques contemporaines pour
les intégrer à une réflexion sociale
globale qui donne le programme de
l'avenir en commun par exemple et c'est
cette on s'entourant également des kips
jeunes effectivement Clémence guetter
pour le programme manuel Bompard qui a
pareil une trentaine d'années qui est
son directeur de campagne toutes les
équipes en fait qui entourent Jean-Luc
Mélenchon il y a une vraie volonté en
fait de s'adapter et de prendre et de
comprendre en fait qu'est-ce qui
traverse non seulement la jeunesse mais
la société de manière générale a envie
de ragir ce qui est étonnant c'est la
bifurcation de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur ce
sur le sujet de des minorités c'est vrai
qu'avant c'était un universaliste
patenté revendiqué il avait autour de
lui toute une toute un lot de personnes
qui qui battait le pavé sur sur ce
combat en particulier en 2017 il lui
manque en effet 600 000 voix il change
de stratégie
il y a des personnes qui virent
littéralement ces personnes là qui
défendaient ce combat républicain
universaliste et il y a de nouvelles
personnes qui arrivent il faut pas se
tromper sur Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est à
dire qu'il est ici d'un mouvement de
d'un courant de la gauche qui s'appelle
le lambertiste pour faire très court
c'est un cours en trop ce qui est trop
de ski voilà exactement qui considère si
je résume que tout ce qui tout ce qui
bouge est rouge donc il faut attraper
toutes les toutes les colères pour en
faire une seule et mener à cette
révolution citoyenne et il y a des
nouvelles colères qui apparaissent à
savoir notamment pas mal de colère dans
les dans les dans les quartiers et les
causes LGBT
les causes aussi sur sur les religions
et notamment l'Islam sur les tous tous
ces communautés là voilà il y a une
colère qui naît donc il veut les saisir
il veut les prendre il y a des nouvelles
personnes qui apparaissent autour de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et je pense notamment
à la député après 2017 à la député
Daniel au Bono
qui elle considère que la France est
impérialiste qui a un système organisé
quasi raciste et donc ces personnes-là
vont murmurer de nouvelles théories à
l'oreille de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il va
finalement digérer pour mener ce nouveau
combat et on arrive en effet à ce que
vous expliquez tout de suite sur le vote
de 2022 mais en fait il fait un choix
politique Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui ne s'y
est pas forcément au même électorat 2017
et qui contredit un peu le Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qu'on a connu depuis
les années 80 je vous laisse répondre on
verra ensuite un dernier résultat du
documentaire je pense que
il faut aussi comment dire comprendre
les quartiers populaires comme les
endroits où le chômage explose l'accès à
l'emploi est extrêmement difficile la
précarité et dans des proportions bien
plus fortes que ailleurs ce sont des
problématiques qu'on retrouve par
ailleurs en zone rurale
des difficultés des accès aux services
publics etc et c'est à cela que l'on
s'adresse avec la hausse du SMIC la
retraite à 60 ans etc mais en plus de
cela Jean-Luc Mélenchon et nous à la
France insoumise nous avons été les
seuls à parler des violences policières
qui que maintenant plus personne ne peut
nier vu l'actualité par ailleurs puisque
dernièrement heureusement revenu au
devant de l'actualité avec les émeutes
qu'on a connus a été tué par la police
ça a commencé comme ça et les violences
policières dans les quartiers c'est
quelque chose contre lequel nous
alertons depuis des années et c'est tout
cela également en fait qui est au cœur
de de ce qui se passe dans les quartiers
populaires en ruralité tous ces endroits
en fait qui ont été où les services
publics ont été enlevés bon et c'est ces
problématiques sociales là que à
auxquelles nous nous adressons en fait
avec notre programme dernière extrait du
commentaire je l'avais promis cette fois
on est là toute fin du film c'est une
réunion familiale on discute des idées
des uns et des autres le père a pas les
mêmes idées que ses enfants la mère non
plus d'ailleurs
mais c'est surtout cette militante qui
réagit à la faire Adrien cadenas au
moment va faire quand j'ai lu sa lettre
bah je me souviens avoir été
très triste pour être honnête
et puis par derrière j'ai pensé aussi à
la victime du coup ça femme et
donc voilà donc
c'est une histoire qui a fait vachement
parler et tant mieux si c'est pour
parler des violences que subissent les
femmes je lui Mélenchon a fait des
tweets du coup qui
qui était pas avancément nécessaire je
pense qui était un peu maladroit et qui
aurait pu être bien meilleur
on a laissé vivre cette image pour
évidemment capter le visage de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on ne sent pas très très à
l'aise et puis on verra que il donnera
une fin de non recevoir aux dernières
questions de la réalité de ce
documentaire suite à cette question
posée concernant cette fameuse affaire
d'Adrien cadenas avec ce jugement
concernant le député Adrien catenas
député du Nord il a été condamné en
décembre dernier à quatre mois de prison
avec sursis suite à des violences
conjugales visiblement ça a laissé
beaucoup de traces et notamment chez les
jeunes qu'on a vu dans ce documentaire
c'est vraiment le cas bah oui en fait ce
qui s'est passé c'était une épreuve pour
la France insoumise parce que
effectivement le logiciel de la France
insoumise a évolué il est devenu très
féministe et tout d'un coup
[Musique]
et là Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui le
reconnaît d'ailleurs dans le
documentaire commet une erreur comme une
erreur c'est à dire qu'il fait un tweet
qui laisse à penser finalement qui
soutient plus son ami Adrien catenens
que culiné apporte son soutien à la
victime et là il une dissonance terrible
rien
sans doute c'est sans doute restait
quelqu'un de très très proche du premier
cercle de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et là
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il revient finalement
une espèce une espèce de vieux logiciel
ancien un peu un peu macho pas très pas
très sensible à cette question là et
dans sa formulation et donc il va se
heurter et on le voit sur le terrain
beaucoup de jeunes le suivent plus en
fait maintenant on pensait que on
pensait qu'il y a des filles étaient
féministe et là il a préféré ne pas
sacrifier son dauphin ne pas ne pas
l'abîmer quitte à froissé en fait des
gens qui sont attachés à lui notamment
des jeunes parce que ils estiment que
c'est une organisation féministe et là
on a vu aussi au sein de la France
insoumise que l'affaire katana ça fait
des dégâts parce que il y a finalement
les proches de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
décide de le soutenir puis à ceux qui
disent bah non non là on a commis une
erreur et donc sur Adrien
c'est une épreuve dans l'organisation et
moi j'ai observé localement beaucoup de
jeunes qui n'ont pas suivi la France
insoumise qui ont fait
la grève du militantisme parce que ils
estiment que finalement
par ce mouvement c'était le cas aussi
dans les rôles dans les groupes
d'actions de la France insoumise c'est
comme ça je crois qu'on appelle ces
groupes qui interviennent localement on
a mal compris la réaction de du leader
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur cette question
précise ce qui est certain c'est que
ce moment qui a été effectivement
requalifié en affaires catenens a
provoqué une réflexion profonde que ce
soit dans le mouvement de la France
insoumise que ce soit dans le groupe
parlementaire on s'est saisi quand même
de de cette histoire là et plus
globalement elle a interpellé chacune et
chacun dans la société et à appeler à se
plonger en soi et à participer à une
réflexion sur ce sujet ça vous a pas
surtout interpellé sur votre mode de
démocratie interne je ne sais pas si
c'était ce sujet là en particulier c'est
des jeunes militants on a vu peut-être
dans ce documentaire sur le même profil
et qui vous ont dit là on comprend pas
qui sont voilà quand on disait des
problématiques contemporaines qui sont
maintenant sur la table ça on fait
partie avec toutes les complexités
toutes les contradictions que cela
entraîne et implique et donc bon tout ça
a donc traversé notre société
votre partie surtout votre mouvement oui
ce qui a rendu peut-être compliqué la
réflexion il faut le dire quand même
c'est la façon dont le traitement
médiatique qui en a été fait qui a
feuilletonné cela et qui permet pas en
fait une réflexion toujours sereine sur
le sujet et d'ailleurs bon même un
jugement
[Musique]
ce que je veux dire c'est que y compris
LCP qui est une chaîne sérieuse
on voit ensuite un extrait Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui se lève qui s'en va mais
ça c'était c'était hors interview par
exemple et ça ça participe à ce
feuilletonnage donc mais si on doit en
tirer un enseignement c'est bien que
c'est une réflexion dont on doit
s'emparer collectivement et qui nous
amène en fait à nous confronter à nos
propres contradictions collectivement et
individuellement et faites mieux
finalement c'est un mot d'ordre qui vaut
pour notre mouvement mais qui vaut de
manière générale pour la société
peut-être pour les médias aussi faites
mieux
au sein de la France insoumise depuis
finalement le
changement de direction de ce moment qui
fonctionne en association en réalité il
y a trois personnes il y a un président
un secrétaire un trésorier alors c'est
Manuel Bompard maintenant le Président
et Madame panot coordinateur
Mathilde pano qui est aussi la
présidente du groupe et les filles qui
est le secrétaire
du mouvement ça a beaucoup tangué depuis
ce passage de relais après Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
notamment dans le cadre de la faire
catenas et dans ce qui s'est passé sur
la démocratie interne la première chose
vous parlez de problématique mais en
fait la jeunesse aujourd'hui dont il
faut tirer les conséquences mais là la
jeunesse aujourd'hui qui vote sur ces
questions notamment
enfin ne veut pas n'a plus le temps ne
veut plus de prendre le temps de
réfléchir à ces questions et cette forme
d'urgence et donc du coup voilà il y a
un sentiment d'urgence et c'est ce qui
manque colère et et finalement il y a un
peu un rétropédalage au sein de la
France insoumise sur cette question
parce que ces électeurs les jeunes
encore une fois ne comprennent pas et il
y a le deuxième rétropédalage sur la
démocratie mais là c'est assez
revendiqué
c'est assez revendiqué au sein de la
France insoumise quand Emmanuel Bompard
dit il y aura jamais de courant et très
peu de vote interne
c'est à dire que il faut savoir que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon a été traumatisé par
ce passage aux parties socialiste parce
que à chaque fois il s'est fait avoir
qu'il y avait souvent des trucages dans
les dans les congrès du Parti socialiste
et qu'il était toujours perdant donc
quand il est parti du Parti socialiste
il ne voulait plus revivre ça et ceux
qui l'ont rejoint pour changer ne
voulaient plus revivre ça non plus et
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui maintenant
qu'il est à la tête de la gauche il ne
veut pas redevenir un parti socialiste
sauf qu'il a accepté de faire une
coalition qui s'appelle la nups et qui
que quelque part l'oblige à revenir à
ces fondamentaux de démocraties internes
et donc à remettre de la démocratie une
minute j'ai mis le feu c'est fini après
ouais ben la France insoumise c'est un
ce qu'on appelle un parti personnel
c'est un parti peu structuré peu ancré
localement structurer autour d'une
personnalité un parti programme aussi et
donc Jean-Luc Mélenchon veut veut pas se
perdre en en
il veut pas se perdre en débat
idéologique interminable du coup c'est à
la fois efficace et en même temps c'est
démocratique voilà donc et ce mélange de
d'efficacité de faible démocratie il est
à la fois performant pour l'excision
présentiel il pose problème pour
d'autres élections il y a des militants
qui s'y retrouvent parce qu'en fait ils
disent voilà on n'a pas besoin de
discuter puisqu'en fait on a un bon
programme et il y a d'autres militants
qui notamment entre les élections
présidentielles eux ils veulent avoir
leur mot à dire ils veulent savoir
pourquoi on désigne tel ou tel candidat
donc c'est un parti qui est un peu dans
un entre deux et qui qui est je le
répète efficace et en même temps parfois
dysfonctionnelle bon ça sera le mot de
la fin vous voulez peut-être ajouter un
mot mais vraiment un mot et en même
temps c'est ce fonctionnement nouveau
que qui n'est pas celui des parties
traditionnelles qui a permis l'émergence
de figures nouvelles et de figures
jeunes y compris dans le groupe des
députés et c'est aussi ce qui apporte de
la force et de l'eau au moulin au moulin
soumis ça sera le mot de la fin comme
promis merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission
consacrée à la relation entre la
jeunesse et la France insoumise à la
jeunesse et solidaire de la France
insoumise qui est qui est encore
aujourd'hui Jean-Luc Mélenchon vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag débat docs
sur Twitter merci à sel massalik m'a
aidé à préparer cette émission et je
vous donne rendez-vous tout simplement
pour un prochain débat doc et ça sera
bien sûr avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]